on à michèle bernier qui est avec nous
michel qu'on adore qui avait signé la
pétition de 100 personnalités du monde
culturel s'engagent à se faire vacciner
dès que ce sera possible ça dumas michel
damour alighieri il s'agit tout le monde
tu me manques michel tu me manques
bah ouais on va se voir j'en ai marre
mois michel taffin et donc la pétition
moi je trouve ça très bien voilà je te
le dis franchement tu vois là parce
qu'il faut il faut moi je pense aussi
comme vous il faut inciter les gens se
vacciner t'as pas hésité une seconde
un pile seconde fois quand j'ai mal à la
tête je pars l'aspirine 6 pour se
soigner contre locaux vides et mc saint
michel comment tu as été que commente a
été contacté pour pourvoir pour signer
la pétition comment ça s'est passé est
ce qu'apple personnalités très
différentes
ça s'est passé tout le monde s'est joint
veut l'un l'autre en disant allez on y
va
est ce que tu es d'accord oui bien sûr
on a tellement envie de revivre
normalement non tellement envie de
revoir nos familles de d'être heureux à
nouveau de se toucher de s'embrasser
tu dois te dire le moral les chênes toi
qui es qui cartonne au théâtre depuis
des années des ânes et enchaîner les
cartons est ce que ça ne manque pas là
tant peu plus la meilleure mais grave
grave cc c'est long c'est difficile
c'est difficile aussi pour tous les gens
qui travaillent autour du spectacle
les techniciens les metteurs en scène
les auteurs les théâtres enfin tous ceux
qui travaillent autour c'est pas
simplement nous les artistes c'est aussi
l'impact sas yeux sur tout ce monde du
travail de de l'événementiel des
concerts tout ça c'est c'est ça qui est
grave
donc il faut savoir que c'est pas juste
nous notre petite bouille connu bien sûr
beaucoup de familles beaucoup de gens
qui ont besoin de retrouver une vie
normale et le vaccin c'est la vie
normale
aujourd'hui on est tous heureux de ne
plus avoir des maladies infectieuses
grâce à la vaccination c'est des vaccins
obligatoires pour les enfants ben
aujourd'hui celui là ne l'est pas encore
mon avis un jour ça sera à fond choix
parce que il faudra bien accepter d'être
vacciné si on veut continuer à vivre
normalement
mais aujourd'hui si vraiment je pense
que l'urgence du gouvernement
aujourd'hui deux de plus
entier d'ailleurs on le voit bien c'est
qu'il ya des pays comme israël çà çà çà
vacciner à tour de bras nous on nous
annonce un vaccin on a envie de la voir
tout de suite c'est bien sûr on en a eu
envie de vivre
mais quand j'entends tous ces gens qui
sont désespérés avec leur métier et
restaurateurs partout dans toutes les
toutes les corporations sont toujours
les gens je sais rien du tout je suis
ambitieux et a dû voir aussi beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent autour de toi qui
doit être désespéré parce que c'est tous
les mecs tous les régisseurs tous les
gens de théâtre tous les gens qui
travaillent derrière et et qu'ils sont
désespérés qu'ils sont vraiment qu'ils
se disent on ne se relèvera jamais de
cette crise on pense fort à eux et on
espère michel combat pendant très fort
et puis on espère vraiment que l'on va
avoir assez de vaccins et vite pour
pouvoir effectivement vacciner les plus
fragiles mais aussi tous ceux qui ont
besoin de vivre et de s'exprimer et de
s'embrasser et de revivre normalement
voilà moi ce concept n'ayez pas peur
n'ayez pas peur
bref que des michel moi je te dis bravo
d'avoir signer la pétition je trouve que
c'est très très belle initiative de tous
ces artistes parce que c'est vous avez
des voix voilà qui porte ces importants
et je pense qu'il faut inciter les gens
à se faire vacciner parce que voilà
aujourd'hui c'est la seule solution on
le voit en tout cas merci michel et j'ai
hâte 2021
c'est le maintien voilà c'est ça bravo
on va garder ça je t'embrasse très fort
michel et jacques de pover syrie
[Applaudissements]